THERE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
GREAT.
GOOD MORNING TO HEARING ON THE
UPCOMING HERE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET I MEAN MEDIA IS CALLED
TO ORDER.
AND WE HAVE ARE ONE VERY
IMPORTANT.
A VERY CONTROVERSIAL ITEM.
YOU KNOW ABOUT A WORKUP IN
TWENTY TWENTIES SIX AND WE HOW
SENATORS TERM PEER TO PRETEND
THE RESOLUTION.
HOPE I'M SORRY I NEED TO
ESTABLISH A CURRENT OF OF GLOBAL
FORUM AND I รณ ASK THE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALDERON.
KANSEN CHU THEIR KANSEN CHU HERE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA HERE ACOSTA HERE DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HERE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE THIS AREA.
WE DO HAVE A CAR.
SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY APOLOGIES TO KEEP --
YOU AWAITING ALTHOUGH THE
INTERNET IS ALWAYS A GOOD
OCCUPIERS TIME --
AS YOU KNOW THE WORLD CUP --
JUST CONCLUDED --
MY STAFF SAYS WITH A STUNNING
FRENCH VICTORY I I JUST I'M
STILL UPSET THAT WE WEREN'T
THERE BUT BUT OUR TIME IS COMING
--
AND IN THE NEXT WORLD CUP WE ARE
GUARANTEED THAT SPOT --
BECAUSE IT WILL BE HERE OF THE
UNITED BID FROM THE U. S. CANADA
AND MEXICO ONE HOSTING RIGHTS
LAST TIME WAS IN --
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SO THEY'RE
NOW OVER THIRTY CITIES VYING TO
HOST GAMES SO THIS MEASURES
REALLY ABOUT TRYING TO GET
PROACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA TO GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE. TO GET OUR
CITIES ORGANIZED TOGETHER
DELEGATION ORGANIZED TO REALLY
SHOW WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
OFFER -- FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE GLOBAL EVENTS
AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF COMMENTS SO
I I DON'T WANT OVER TALK THIS
AND IF YOU HAVE SUGGESTIONS.
I KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE THIS
RESOLUTION BUT THE THING I'M
MOST INTERESTED IN IS TRYING TO
FIND THOSE SORT OF KEY POCKETS
IN THE STATE.
AS IN YOUR DISTRICT ARE OUR
BACKYARD IN LA WHERE WE CAN
REALLY --
LEVERAGE THIS OPPORTUNITY TALK
ABOUT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AROUND THE CUP
ALSO EXPLORING WHAT OTHER CITIES
IN THE COUNTRY ARE DOING IN MAY
BE LEARNING FROM THEM AND
SHARING SOME OF THOSE BEST
PRACTICES AND IN THE LEAD UP TO
IT SO.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL WORTH MORE
HOME TO THREE MLS THOUSAND YOUTH
AND ADULT PLAYERS --
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU ALL KNOW
THAT THE THE HEROES ALEX MORGAN
LANDON DONOVAN MEGAN RAPINOE --
SO -- LOOK
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDS AND
RESPECT THE ASTRO.
THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL AND
ALSO.
MISTER CHAIR OF A QUICK QUESTION
YES I'M JUST OFFENDED THAT I'M
NOT A ACOSTA ON THIS BILL.
I SENATOR SO WOULD LOVE TO ADDED
GOING TO REMEDY THAT.
AND IT WAS A THANK YOU FROM THE
CITY WITH THE LARGEST AYSO
CHAPTER IN THE UNITED STATES I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
COOPER ARE YOU ALSO OFFENDED.
OR I I AM NOT UNLESS OFFENDED A
GUY MORE CONSUMER CONFUSED
LOOKING GOOD.
YES I WOULD LOVE TO ACCEPT THOSE
REQUESTS [inaudible]
ANYTHING [inaudible]
OVER [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WHAT DO I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND NOT A COUPLE OFFENDED
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS POINT I'D LIKE --
TO AND SENATOR YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING OUR A MIXTURE.
YES ON THE COMING I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
AS THIS MOVES ALONG HOPEFULLY
THIS RESOLUTION PASSES AND AND
REALLY TRYING TO USE THE POWER
THIS COMMITTEE WHICH I THINK IS
A GOOD TREMENDOUS RESOURCE IN
THIS REGARD. TO START TO SHOW
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO OFFER TO
REALLY PUT THAT PLAN TOGETHER SO
GOVERNOR TO BE HAPPY WITH TWO OF
WORK WITH YOU.
ON THIS SHOW --
MADERA SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. R. ONE FOURTEEN STERN TO
BE ADOPTED AND THAT AS AMENDED
AND SENT TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE.
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
TREATMENT NINE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MS AREA.
THIS AREA QUESTIONABLE AYE YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE
AGO THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
BELIEF DO A ROLL OVER HOME
FLORIDA.
WE'LL NEVER SEE AWARD.
EVEN MORE THAN LA SYDNEY WE GOT
WE GOT NO WORK POLITICAL AND
OKAY.
I DON'T OFFEND THE COST ALRIGHT
QUE [inaudible]
YEAH
.
ALL RIGHT IN MEETINGS FOR JOINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH